bonjour moi c'est amélie j'ai 17 ans et
j'ai la maladie que tissent laksaci on
fabian des routes affaissées your mind
feat mc ito convient pas là que je
t'explique
même tendance
c'est une maladie de naissance et
qui fait un vieillissement de la peau
c'est comme si quand on n'avait pas les
élastiques et tout ça dans la peau et du
coup ça fait un relâchement pour ma part
cette maladie est juste sur mon visage
et non sur le reste de mon corps donc
c'est vraiment les joues qui se relâche
un petit peu et un peu les cernes et
tout ça mais c'est tout
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment compris que je l'avais à
peut-être en 2019 j'ai vraiment compris
mais avant oui je savais mais pas à ce
point je savais pas le nom de la maladie
je savais pas ce que c'était je ne te
connaissais rien de tout ça pour le nom
de la maladie je l' ai appris que grâce
à tik tok justement et j'en avais jamais
parlé avec mes parents donc ils m'ont
jamais rien dit à propos de ce sujet et
tout le reste c'est pareil tik tok je me
suis c'est les gens qui m'ont informé
sur sa et en a qui m'ont dit que
j'allais mourir à 14 ans etc c'est faux
j'en ai 17 je suis toujours là mais
en fait quand on vieillit on va vieillir
comme une personne normale ou personnes
âgées en fait et on sera comme une
personne âgée on peut soigner cette
maladie en faisant de la chirurgie
esthétique mais malheureusement cela ne
tiendra pas et il faudra refaire tous
les 2-3 ans grand max et du coup je n'en
trouve pas l'utilité j'ai surmonté tout
ça grâce à ma famille parce que je suis
pas la seule à l'avoir
du coup
on en a rigolé entre nous on en rigole
tous les jours après c'est pas facile
pour certains mais nous on en rigole et
je préfère en rigoler qu'en pleurer là
il ya ben mami encore 18 ans pour
l'interrogation c'est la grand mère à
qui ça encore
hélas ce genre de commentaires j'ai
envie de leur répondre bah bien la chute
à granby en fête j'ai voulu me lancer
sur les réseaux sociaux de base parce
que c'était vraiment quelque chose qui
me faisait passer mon temps mais au
final j'ai remarqué qu'il y avait des
gens qui s'intéressait vraiment à ma
maladie qui s'intéressait vraiment à moi
et qui était vraiment là pour moi du
coup j'ai continué dans ma lancée et de
faire plaisir aux gens en faisant des
vidéos je me sens beaucoup rassuré grâce
aux personnes qui sont dans les
commentaires et qui me défendent
d'autres sur mes lives et franchement ça
rassure je vis cette maladie très bien
c'est quelque chose qui limite m'a fait
ma force dans la vie de tous les jours
parce que bas les critiques en fait ils
m'ont renforcée ils ont renforcé ma
personne et ils ont fait la personne que
je suis maintenant je trouve que ta
maladie te donne un vrai charme
[Rires]
carrément pour une fois qu'il ya des
personnes qui sont pas là à dénigrer et
justement à trouver
à trouver un charme dans une maladie
franchement nul ça fait plaisir d'être
sur les réseaux c'est un très très bon
moyen de s'accepter oui au lieu de se
montrer en vrai on se montre derrière un
écran donc déjà beaucoup plus facile
pour les personnes qui sont pas très
sociable alors d'aujourd'hui le regard
des gens c'est quelque chose qui me fait
rire parce que forcément quand on croise
des gens dans la rue ils ne comprennent
pas et savent pas ce que c'est je peux
comprendre que ça sa puissante il
intrigue et tout ce qui s'ensuit mais
des fois c'est drôle c'est drôle je les
accepte en me disant que dans la vie il
ya toujours pire
donc je pars du principe qu'il ya pire
que moi
je n'ai pas le droit de me plains de
quelque chose de si peu grave donc alors
d'actu à l'heure actuelle jeu
me fie pas à ce que moi j'aime et je
m'inquiète plus pour les autres sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est vraiment aider les
personnes à s'accepter tels qu'ils sont
malgré qu'on est tous nos différences
tous nos maladies où certains en ont pas
mais c'est vraiment de de pouvoir aider
tout le monde et être là pour tout le
monde et si jamais il ya des problèmes
mais on se contacte et on en parle
ensemble mais c'est vraiment ça le but
que je veux faire ressentir sur les
réseaux